Hello world. It's Saroj and evolution.
It's the reason we're all here today.
In today's video,
we're going to use tensorflow dot js to
simulate the process of evolution in our
browser.
What you're seeing behind me is the
demo that we're going to code in today's
video. What it's doing is it's using
a bunch of different neural networks,
and it's using evolutionary strategies
to evolve all of these neural networks
over time to learn how to walk from the
left end of the screen to the right end
of the screen.
So every generation,
a new breed or new generation
in every generation,
a new generation of neural
networks are going to be bread,
and then they're all going to try to
walk from the left side of the screen to
the right side. Now we're at generation
seven. They're getting a little better.
They're still kind of jumpy,
and they don't really move that much.
We can take one and even we can even
like move it across like all right,
it's gone. But, uh, yeah,
it's using tensorflow dot js to do
this and and evolutionary algorithms.
It's the combination of neural networks
and evolutionary techniques put together
that can allow us to evolve a
population over time. And this,
this has some real use cases and I'm going
to talk about those in today's video.
We're going to code this intention
flow dot js at the end of the video.
But I want to start off by talking
about neuro evolution. Okay,
so machine learning models,
neural networks in particular,
neural networks are function
approximators. That means
they're really, really,
really good at approximating
the correlation between
some input data and some
output data. Right to the input data
could be images, that can be videos,
it could be numbers and the output data
could be labels. They could be, you know,
hot dog,
not hot dog,
that could be one through 10 they could
be the price of a stock on a given day.
They could be the notes for a
musical composition, whatever.
But it's the label and there is some
mapping between the inputs and the output
data. And neural networks are really
good at learning that mapping.
And the way we do this is using a
technique called gradient descent. Okay.
So creating dissent is all about finding
those optimal values by finding what's
called the, the, the minimum
in some valley, right?
So if we were to map all of the
parameters versus the output values,
you'd find some value. And we want to
find the bottom of that point, right?
So it looks like this,
and what gradient descent
does is iteratively and
every time step it tries to
find this minimum value. And once it finds
that minimum value, we could say, okay,
we've got this minimum point.
What is the,
what is the coefficient values at
this point? So in this three, um,
and this three access model, we have
a z access, a y axis and an x axis.
So in the x and y axis represent
the two parameters of a model.
And the Z axis is the objective.
It's, it's that output value.
And we can try and guess
what those values are, but,
but by using gradient descent and we
can learn what the optimal values are,
and the way to do this is right gradient
descent. That's how it's done so far.
But in the 80s a couple of
researchers thought, okay,
what if we use a different
optimization technique?
What if we don't use gradient descent?
And if we think about life on earth, you,
me, animals, bacteria,
we're all neural networks.
We all have these networks of neurons
in our head and we're learning through
trial and error. And the, the,
the local learning procedure could be
whatever, right? We don't know what it is,
but the more macro learning procedure
through our children and their children
and their children is this
process of evolution, right?
So we are adapting to our climate,
we're adapting to our, our scenery,
we're adapting to our environment,
the context of where we lived and we
pass on these adaptions in the form of
genes to our children.
And that process is evolution.
And that in and of itself
is a learning technique.
And what evolutionary algorithms neuro
evolution does is it tries to model that
process in simulation in Silico,
inside of a machine.
And so if we think about a bunch
of different neural networks,
we can randomly initialize all of them.
So they all start out
with random weight values.
And what we can do is we can pick the
best one by some measure of whatever best
means for our objective,
and then we can take that best neural
network out of say a hundred and then say,
okay, this neural network
is the best of all of them.
Let's let's create a bunch of other
neural networks that are very slight
variation from this best one,
and that's the new population.
And then out of those there's going to
be the best one and we'll take that and
we'll breathe it with
another and then we'll,
we'll repeat that process
over and over again.
So we're just kind of simulating
evolution that's so high level.
I'm going to go into the details
of how that works in a second,
but what I want to say here,
what my point is that my point is that
gradient descent works really well.
If you look at all of
the production systems,
grading dissent is the
optimization strategy also
called backpropagation in the
context of neural networks. It is the
optimization strategy that is used.
However,
with Uber,
with a bunch of new startups
and Uber and some big companies,
I'll talk about more and more
companies, users, startups,
researchers are using evolutionary
strategies, neuro evolution,
genetic algorithms to optimize
their neural networks.
And I'll talk about those in a
second. Okay, so think about it.
Grading dissent is us trying to find
that minimum point by starting at some
point and then see an Eruv Lee going
closer and closer to that ideal value.
If you want to look, if you want to know
how backpropagation works, how grading,
dissent works, search
backpropagation and Saroj on Youtube,
I've backpropagation and five minutes
video could super useful. Okay, so,
so it typically goes like this,
like I said,
we will generate a population of let's
say a hundred random neural networks,
right? So we don't know what
those initial weight values are.
So in the context of neural networks,
those perimeters would be wait values,
right?
So you know this,
this is initialized with some
random group of numbers of vector,
of weight values. Another one is
with another group of way to values.
And we will then determine the arc.
And all of those architectures are
determined using some distribution, right?
So some golf, Sian distribution,
et cetera. Then we'll select,
select the best neural network by some
fitness function. We'll talk about that.
We'll let's say three or four of them.
We'll breed them together.
By breeding it means,
you know,
it could be a dot product between
those wait values. It could be, uh,
finding those optimal parameters and,
and then choosing those for the next one,
etc. What does weight values are copying
them and then create these offspring,
which are new neural networks.
And then we'll repeat that process
over and over and over again.
So there are a couple of
genetic algorithms out there.
There's neat neuro evolution
of augmented topologies.
There's hyper neat, there's novelty
search. There are quite a lot of examples.
So the idea here is that we start off
with some neural networks and then we
evaluate all of their,
how fit each of them are.
So that means checking where the models
are and the optimization surface,
which of the models performed best.
And then selection is performed
based on that fitness evaluation.
We'll select four or five,
whatever threshold value we decide
and evolutionary strategies.
The offspring is reduced to a single
model and weighted by the fitness
evaluation.
So for deep neural networks,
the fitness is defined as
the loss or the reward,
and essentially we're moving around
the optimization surface and using the
offspring to get in the
right direction so that the,
the key difference between gradient
descent here is that instead of computing
the gradients,
we're sending out multiple antennas and
moving in the direction that looks best.
There's not a single model that
we're optimizing. There are several.
There's a population of models that's,
that's the big difference here, right?
So if you think about there's,
there's six of these models here.
Think of each of them has, as
all of these rows, each model,
one model equals one row.
We'll select the best ones will
combine those values using some kind of
technique, maybe. Dot. Product,
multiplication, division, whatever.
Then will mutate them.
That means we're very them in some way,
and then we'll place those mutated
offspring in back into the population and
then try and try again. The process
repeats over and over again. In this way,
it's similar to a
structured random search,
but the end result is in the selection
phase that we have a single model and
then we repeat that process over
and over and over and over again.
So this is an example of Uber. So this,
this map I, I took from Uber, right?
So there are engineering a website.
So they have this great blog on neuro
evolution, which I have a link to,
but basically what one
technique they used, one, one
real life use case. We'll see,
use evolutionary strategies
to evolve this, uh,
pathfinding algorithm to get from the
best route from point a to point B.
And this is the map of, of, of what
they found to be that, that best route.
And so, uh, so applied to
neural networks specifically,
we can use genetic algorithms
to optimize any kind of model.
It doesn't have to be a neural
network and it can be, you know,
some simple function. It can be some, um,
it could be anything really.
And a neural network really
is just a nested function.
And every layer is another layer
of nesting that function, you know,
f of x is one layer,
and then m of f of x is two layers.
And then g of F of f of x is a three
layer network. You see what I'm saying?
Because we're taking the output of one
function and using it as input to the
next function and using the output of
that function it and using it as input to
the next function. So it's, it's, it's
this, it's this nested function, right?
So however many layers is
another layer of nesting.
So applied to a neural network. If we
apply neuro evolution to that. So what is,
what is that thing that we want to
optimize? What we want to optimize,
the number of layers, the neurons
per layer, the activation function,
the network optimizer, these
are all different parameters
that we could optimize.
And so when it comes to use cases,
it really just boils down to anything
that could use a neural network and that
could improve on the backpropagation
optimization strategy.
So Uber found actually in their blog
was that neuro evolution outperformed
graded descent in terms
of time to convergence.
So they'd spend up this Atari game,
this,
this deep Q learner that you know took
deep mind like days and days on massive
sets of gps to compute into a
single hour on a desktop CPU. Um,
which is really cool.
So just check that out.
I have a link to it in the video
description, but so like I said,
it can be applied to anything that
neural networks are currently applied to.
If there is some,
um,
if there is some AI that is
using backpropagation right
now that is slow in some
way where a 2%, 3%, 5%,
10% increase can be useful.
That would be a perfect time to
apply this technique to write.
You can outperform the competition by
using an evolutionary strategy, right?
So this could be applied to self
driving cars, better game AI,
image classifiers,
like clarify our generation.
Really anything that's
using neural networks.
So you can apply in neuro evolution
too to make that optimization process
faster.
That's what it comes down to.
A faster optimization process
that converges to a better
minimum, faster, right?
So you can get better results and
faster if you are using neat algorithms.
Most of the time from what we've
seen here and some of these examples,
especially the Uber blog, um,
but also Google, so Google
uses, uses it for auto ml.
They're automatic machine learning
algorithm that you can try in the browser.
Um, and deepmind used it
recently, so did mine,
did neuro evolution for pup,
they called it population based training.
I remember it was like
population based training,
population based
training of neural networks.
That's what they called it. Yes.
And this was released less
than a year ago. But um, yeah,
some great blog posts on that as well.
They've got some nice little
visualizations of using them on generative
adversarial networks. Great use
case, popular model. So yeah,
there's a ton of use cases.
But in today's video I want to talk about
using it in the context of tensorflow.
Dot.
Js.
It says the hottest machine learning
library right now because it allows us to
create an l models in the browser that
anybody can access on any kind of device,
mobile embedded device,
TV, um, laptop, desktop.
And it's, it's really utilizing
the power of transfer learning,
which we haven't really seen when
it comes to python or c plus plus.
For some reason it's just people are
using, uh, pretrained models much more.
And I think it's because it's
a lot easier for one and two.
It's using Java script, which has a
much bigger user base right there.
More programmers using javascript these
days. So before we get to our model,
I just want to say two quick
things about tensorflow. Dot.
Js to remember there is the core Api,
right?
So the core Api is what
we're going to use,
but it lets us build a computation graph
and we could think of a computation
graph as a neural network.
It's because it's just a
series of operations that
tensors data flows between.
And these operations can be layers. They
can be, you know, whatever, you know,
different operations like adding,
subtracting,
depending on the type of
architecture you want a,
but it's very simple to do in Java script.
Here's a simple example.
We have two tensors a and B.
We add them together,
we print them out just like that.
And that those are two nodes
in the computation graph,
a, B plus, and that output,
that's the computation graph. Three nodes
in the graph, a, B, and then the total,
the output of a and B.
So that's,
that's what we're going to use because
this is a very simple neural networks
that we're going to build.
However,
when it comes to more complex
neural networks with much more late,
many more layers and you know,
many different, you know,
strategies like attention,
um, momentum, et Cetera, then we
want to use the high level API,
which is the layers API. So layers
API lets us it packages together,
both the variable and the operations
that act on Tim and act on them into a
single function. So one example would
be this, so that the layers dot dense,
uh,
line of code,
it performs a weighted sum across all
inputs of each output and applies an
optional activation function.
So it's combining,
but the variable and the
operation into a single line,
which doesn't seem like that big a deal.
But when you're creating a big neural
network, it saves a lot of time.
It's basically care os in the browser.
That's what it is.
Think of that as an analogy. Care Os and
the browser. A single line per layer.
Okay, so now let's get to
our model. So in our model,
what we're going to have are these
creatures and each of these creatures is a
three layer feed forward neural network.
That's their brain that we see right here.
That right there was a bunch of creatures.
Right now in this generation,
there's only one. But if I refresh, we're
going to, we're going to get a lot more,
but we're going to go, that's
a lot of creatures, right?
So each of them has
their own neural network.
So the input data that's fed into the
network are four different parameters.
The horizontal velocity,
how fast they're moving horizontally,
the vertical velocity, how fast
we're moving up and down. The torque,
how fast they're turning,
and the height above the ground level.
So the score, the, the,
the way that we are, um,
scoring these, these, uh, creatures
is we're saying they can gain points
based on the distance that it travels from
the starting point. So the further
it travels in the correct direction,
the more points that gain. So if it
goes from left all the way to the right,
it's gonna get a lot of points.
And then traveling in the opposite
direction is going to reduce the point.
So the fitness function, the
way we define how fit, um,
a neural network is in this context
is that how far a creature goes,
the selection algorithm that says,
let's see what are the best most fit
neural networks here is to select based on
their fitness value will, which
will be a scalar, a single value.
And that's going to be that that
fitness value is going to act like the
probability of being
chosen for reproduction.
The creatures that perform better
have higher fitness values.
And hence have a higher chance of
reproducing when it comes to crossover
breeding, reproduction, W, whatever
you want to call it, two creatures.
These parents are selected
using the selection algorithm.
Their weights are interchange randomly
in our case. And then finally,
mutation is a single value, a
parameter that's going to change, uh,
the probability of introducing
randomness to each of these networks.
So let's get into the code here.
Okay,
so I want to start off by just
creating a simple neural network.
This will be an 40 lines of code.
We're going to use tensorflow dot js.
So I'm going to call this
a neural network class,
and let me make sure that it's using
javascript as its base javascript.
There we go. Okay, so it's going to
be called class neural network. Okay.
And in this class neural network,
I want there to be a constructor.
The constructor, we'll define what the
input to this neural network will be.
We want some,
a certain number of input nodes.
We want a certain number
of hidden nodes or neurons,
and we want a certain set of output notes.
Okay?
So then inside of the constructor,
we're going to define what those input
nodes are, what those hidden nodes are,
and that's going to make them
accessible inside of the class, right?
So for all three of them,
I'm going to do the same thing.
And so these values are going to be
accessible later on in the class as I
manipulate them with
inside of other functions.
The next step is I'm going to initialize
random waits for that neural network,
right?
Because when our creatures start out,
they're going to be randomly
initialized weights, right?
Because there's no learning happening yet.
And so now I'm going to actually use
tensorflow dot. JS and like I said before,
we're going to use,
we're going to,
we're going to generate these wait values
randomly from a distribution and and
distribution.
And so to do this,
we can use the what's called
the random normal function.
So from a normal distribution,
we're going to generate a set of weights.
And the way to do this is to say,
well, how many input notes do we have?
And then how many hidden nodes do we have?
And then based on those values,
we can generate a set of weights. And
then once we have that, we could say,
well that's our input weights and now
we want to have one more set of weights,
right? Output weights. Because this is
a, a three layer, like I said before,
neural network. And then between each of
those three layers is a set of weights.
And because there are three layers,
there are then two sets of weights.
And so because there are two
sets of weights were we'll
create those two sets of
weights. And because I had, um,
the input notes and then
hidden knows for the first,
I'll have the hidden nodes and I'll put
notes for the next set of weights. Okay.
So now we've initialized our random weight
values and now that we've done that,
we can create the predict function,
right? So we have our neural network,
it's constructed and we want to
create a predict function, right?
So that the user will
do is they will input
some data,
right?
So this is going to be some input data
and we'll talk about what that input data
is, but it's going to take that input
data and we're going to define some output
variable.
So now I'm going to use the tidy function.
Tensorflow is a tidy function and what
this is going to do is it's going to cry.
I'm going to use this as a rapper and
then inside of that rapper I'm going to
actually create my neural network.
So before what I did was I initialize
those values and now I'm actually going to
create the neural network itself
using those values at created before.
What tidy does is it executes a
function and it frees up any GPU memory.
So because we're about
to create this network,
I'm going to use the tidy function to
execute this neural network and as a
function and then free up any GPU memory
that I have because this is going to
require some GPU memory right now.
So this is going to end.
This is going to take
an one d array as input.
So for the first layer I'm going to say,
well,
I'm going to input a tensor using and
then that tensor is going to be created
using what the input data
is from the user rights
and the size of that is going
to be the input nodes sides.
That's the first part. The next
part is for us to say, well,
what's the hidden layer?
The hidden layer is going
to be the input layer,
but we're going to matrix multiply it
by the the set of weight values that we
had that we defined before,
right?
So inside of the constructor and we're
going to apply the sigmoid function to
that because input times wait, activate.
That's going to activate that result.
If you want to know why I'm using
the sigmoid function, watch my video,
build a neural network in four minutes.
Now that we have that, we can just,
we can use,
we can create the output layer because
this is a three layer feed forward neural
network and I'm going to do the same
exact thing because neural networks are
giant nested functions.
I'm going to take the output of the first
function and use it as input to this
function.
And I'll say this thought,
how put weights dot sigmoid.
And lastly,
now I have my output,
which is going to be the output from
the output layer. Dot data sync.
We're just going to sink the result
into a single scalar value that I can,
I can have as my output,
and now I can return that output.
So that's it for the predict function.
Now I have two more functions
that I want to create.
So the first function is called clone.
So what the clone function
doing is it's going to say,
let's create a Kloni.
And what it's going to do is it's going
to create a clone of our neural network
because we'll want that at the start.
We want to create a bunch of
different neural networks, right?
And so this function is going to do that.
So we'll just call this function
over and over and over, over again.
And so whenever a population
is initialized, we'll clap.
We'll call this function.
However, for however many neural
networks we want there to be.
And now that we defined
the neural network class,
we can just say create a new
neural network, use, you know,
whatever number of input nodes you want,
whatever number of hidden nodes you want.
And then whatever number of,
I'll put notes you want. Once
we have that. So we'll say,
well now we can
dispose of anything in memory that we
don't want so we can clear up some memory.
And then we will say,
here are the input weights.
Clone the ones that we already have,
TF dot clone function.
And here are d.
Wait.
Okay.
Okay. So now that we've done
that, we have our input ways,
we have our output weights,
we've quoted our neural network,
and now we can return it and glass Lee.
Now that we have all of that,
so we can finally just say dispose,
which we'll dispose the input in help,
what for memory, which we'll
call at the end of a generation.
And once we have that,
we're done with our neural network class.
Now we can look at the rest of the
code and I'll just copy paste.dot dot.
And then this is going to be output.
Okay, so that's our simple class.
Say that. So in the context
of our genetic algorithm,
we have a genetic algorithm class and
this is just an example of how it works.
We'll initialize the creature.
The creature will be a neural network,
will define what it looks
like in inside of the space,
like the visualization by these,
these values right here.
And then we'll define some way of
picking one of those, one of those, um,
neural networks or creatures by
defining some threshold value.
And if it's over that threshold value
that is our selected that as our selected
network and will return that.
Now we can say it,
let's evolve our neural network.
So a sign of fitness to each creature.
We'll pick the best one and then we'll
breed them by picking two parents that
define a child.
And you think this crossover functions
to define what the child's weights are
and then push that child to
a new generation and repeat
that process for all of
those values, which are children
inside of that generation, Hooray
will kill the current
generation iteratively.
And an add new children to
the generation population.
So this is the genetic
algorithm class as as a whole.
This is the neural
network class as a whole.
And now we can look at how this
has combined in sketch dot j yes,
so this is how it works. We define the
canvas, what everything looks like.
We'll initialize a generation, a person
or creature, we can call it whatever,
and we'll, we'll say, let's
define a bunch of them.
We'll add it to the world will
define the world's boundaries,
the mouse constraint.
This is just visual visualization stuff
in javascript and we'll say, well,
let's restart a generation every five
seconds now when we'll have a counter for
that and we'll display the stats for that.
Okay,
and so the real, the real
meat of this here, I said,
just initialize this population
right here and we'll just say,
just keep doing that over and over and
over again. So generation dot evolve.
That's it for today's video.
I hope you found it useful.
If you want any more cool information,
it's going to be in the video description.
I've got the code, help her
links everything for you. Uh,
check it out if you want to evolve
to the next level in terms of your
programming expertise and your life,
hit the subscribe button for now.
I've got to evolve myself,
so thanks for watching.